the Joe Rogan experience yeah how long
have you been living in Hawaii uh well
my mom took me from San Francisco when I
was six months old whoa
pretty much it was only a technicality
what that I wasn't born there which
actually worked against me it's cuz you
know when you're not born then when
you're not born there then you're not
from there right there law you're not
mourning right and you're like oh yeah
but I I've been here since I was you
know since I can remember so let's just
put it that way
right but my memory actually worked they
still hold it against you the six months
that you were oh yeah oh yeah we missed
you bro oh yes months where were ya you
were out if your mother here is in the
state but now but yeah since I was a
little kid I mean I my mom took me I was
born in San Francisco and she took me
when I was a few months old I have a
theory about people from Hawaii
there's a groundedness that they seem to
exhibit that is universal it's almost
you very rarely find completely
frivolous dopey people that live in
Hawaii they do not
yeah sure you find some people they're
not that smart but you there's a
groundedness there that's so many of
them have because they're on a volcano
yeah one ocean and you know is
interesting that you talk about that
because yesterday we were having a
conversation about what is that right
and we have a couple terms one of them
is mana which is the power from the land
another one is Aloha which is our kind
of a spirit of how people act from
Hawaii but I believe it has a lot to do
with Islanders I think Islanders have
that and it has a lot to do with it has
a lot to do with the ocean being around
the ocean that the oceans surrounding
you and the ocean is the most conductive
substance on earth so
elec electrically and there's all this
thing so you get influenced by this you
know and I think energetically the
nature is so powerful I think it puts us
into there's a certain kind of humility
that you have when you're in that you're
next to a volcano that's 14,000 foot and
you got a 2,000 foot waterfall and you
got a giant wave I mean this is stuff
that kind of goes oh yeah we're just
little ants weirdest little specks and
we don't it's humbling but it's also
inspiring and energizing yeah
power right the menthe the mana yeah
I've always wondered what people that
live in beach communities they're so
chill like I've wonder is that because
of just the humility that you get when
you just look in the ocean welcome right
have you ever seen that book no it's
called the blue mind the guys pretty
interesting and it does a study of why
we gravitate towards being on the beach
why all the most expensive real estate
is beachfront and that's something about
when we stare at the ocean they did all
these studies where them it just totally
lights the brain up that our whole
something about the horizon and about
the ocean itself that that affects our
whole well-being hmm and and part of it
we don't even know why but we're just
drawn like why you know why is why are
we drawn there why do we you know and
and it has it has a you know an effect
on our system I wonder if that's because
we evolved to be close to the water
because that's where the bounty is where
you can get fish and while we evolved
from the water that true